[Music]
the greatest gamer on youtube
i have the most subscribers which means
i have the most skill
oh this game is a little hard
it's just like a dog so i asked you
to challenge me for real i ask you hey
give me a real game
give me a real challenge you should play
i want to be the guy that's a really
hard game it's just like
[Music]
jesus christ
i want to be the guy the movie the game
so you jump with
shift what the [ __ ] are these controls
i must be able to shoot then okay i can
okay okay fine oh the game is hard they
say
oh
whatever zero depths let's do that again
hey
whoa okay here we go oh the game is so
hard
oh wow look how hard that game was easy
trap
anyone can see through that get the [ __ ]
away from me trap
all right next level
zero deaths this is the easiest game
i've ever played in my life i just have
to stand here oh wow
that is super hard that's like straight
up impossible
all right oh i wonder what the next one
is gonna do
all right i gotta run
oh wow with this oh
what the [ __ ] was that shut up what the
[ __ ]
how the hell am i going to give me that
oh that one touched my nip i like it
do it again please come back i love you
i love you please stay with me i wanna
missed me this is not hard this is
memorizing
a series of pattern which is child's
play
anyone can do this anyone
give me a challenge that requires skill
with these magical fingers okay give me
that
what the [ __ ] am i doing wrong there it
just hits me anyway whatever [ __ ] am i
supposed to do
my god this is so boring i have to wait
for this [ __ ] every
time oh wait i can't swear because the
video will get demonetized
i mean no this is go
go jump over there you didn't jump
you mower on go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go
you didn't jump what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you i get it now
i can't i got it before i started i just
wanted to pretend that i'm bad
just so you feel bad about yourself just
so you feel like oh maybe he's not that
good
good okay watch this first time ever
play this game i bet you had to watch
tutorials to play this game
oh wow i beat dark souls on my
third try yeah did you look online
people playing it on youtube
because then it doesn't count you didn't
jump
oh wait he can double jump oh
oh oh i see you can play with easy mode
fine fine because i am the guy
double jump i'm like jump
all right look at this why is it not
coming now
how am i supposed to make it all the way
how oh my god this game is so dumb
to play and beat games i
absolutely love that's offensive that
every other game in the world you don't
have to think not played a zelda game
before they straight up
oh my god that's so offensive go go
go go go go go
hit me how do i get there
right how do i get there i just walk
down
i dump what happened to double jumping
huh what happened to double jumping
huh does it count as a jump did you walk
off
idiocy this game is stupid stupid game
you stupid i mean it's
barely scratch the surfaces i mean this
thing oh i get it i get it now
i get it now look at me look at me look
at me meet me
okay look and then we go back up
this is the first stage so i'm pretty
walk here now but as soon as i hit a
certain
point the thing activates
there
but how in the love of da how in the
love of [ __ ]
how am i supposed to make that jump how
how am i supposed
to make that
jump how is that even physically
possible
it's way too there must be a way
with these these brown things in the
back there must be a way with them
there's some secret to them
oh i know i got it i got it before you
got it
shush you shush you i got it
i got it okay i don't need you to tell
me oh beautiful what you need to do it
it's so obvious it's so obvious beauty
oh oh
no no no no no no no look at that
genius so smart you see that [ __ ]
oh i i beat the game
too it was easy you tutorial looking
little flannels
okay okay can we move on now
easy this game is easy you see uh we
haven't hit the save yet oh god there's
gonna be a trap here by the same
thank you not on my got it
got it oh wow the spike's still down
oh what is this one gonna shoot up oh
wow oh what are the apples going to
attack i mean
oh wow let me guess the water makes me
survive
you don't die in water great now what
the [ __ ] do i do then
there best not be two apples in that
spike if there's two waffles in the
sponge
this guy is not gonna be happy
okay we got it
wow okay those apples cannot be trusted
they are going to shoot vertically ah
that's right i'm gonna shoot you
okay you can't shoot the apples but
that's fine
since when does apple kill anything shut
up apples
talk what did i say has anyone ever died
from an apple
we need to trigger this app
this game is about triggering apples
look at the pure gaming skill okay look
oh wow the apples
see i'm one step ahead i thought they
would go vertically but no they did not
oh god that apple i don't trust for one
second
great great
just what i wanted all right
let's take it easy take it easy
stay gay so we
shut up you have to trigger all the
apples then the
comet won't come it's an old trick
my grandpa told me all about it hey
poots
if there's ever a comet trigger all the
apples
i know you're thinking oh pewdiepie has
given up now
he can't do it i could do anything i
want
that's why i'm calling you
ah you can't make that jump
not today comet all right fine comment
you win this round the game is hard
because
you have to learn how the game works i
looked it up online
but that's fine because i'm gonna keep
come on comet
come on comment come on comment
don't you want to live forever
okay so we gotta trigger these two
apples by jumping to them
as close as humanly possible
not today not today apples not today
not anybody because i am the apple
master
of disaster oh comment oh comment
oh oh no not the comment anything
it keep following you are you kidding me
what the hell
not today mr apples i'm gonna trigger
this one too because i don't have time
for you and your oh my lord
okay here it comes mr comment please
oh no no
no no
ah oh i'm here um oh it's getting on
it's getting on
oh jeez
no
come on come on come on
oh oh oh this game is so
hard oh it keeps following me
it keeps following me why
am i why did he do that why didn't he
oh no
you can't change this
leave me alone leave me alone
bye okay all right let's take it
really nice and easy over here i can
shoot
can i jump a link i can't jump here okay
i'm safe
here oh my god okay
okay let's go in his
save shut up about your sword old man
thank you
oh my god oh
my god oh my god
oh my god what is this
game it's so easy now play give me this
it didn't call me
[Music]
i'm ending this episode here but this is
not over
this is just the beginning apples
you think you can beat me the best
player in the world
leave a like if you want part two and
i'll say you know
squad fam jujitsu out